Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Style transfer is a technique in machine learning
research where we have two input images, one
for content, and one for style, and the output
is our content image reimagined with this
new style.
The cool part is that the content can be a
photo straight from our camera, and the style
can be a painting, which leads to the super
fun results that you see here.
An earlier paper had shown that the more sophisticated
ones can sometimes make even art curators
think that they are real.
This previous work blew me away as it could
perform style transfer for smoke simulations.
I almost fell out of the chair when I have
first seen these results.
It could do fire textures, starry night, you
name it.
It seems that it is able to do anything we
can think of.
Now let me try to explain two things.
One, why is this so difficult, and two, the
results are looking really good, so, are there
any shortcomings?
Doing this for smoke simulations is a big
departure from 2D style transfer, because
that one takes an image, where this works
in 3D, and does not deal with images, but
with density fields.
A density field means a collection of numbers
that describe how dense a smoke plume is at
a given spatial position.
It is a physical description of a smoke plume,
if you will.
So how could we possibly apply artistic style
from an image to a collection of densities?
The solution in this earlier paper was to
first, downsample the density field to a coarser
version, perform the style transfer there,
and upsample this density field again with
already existing techniques.
This technique was called Transport-based
Neural Style Transfer, TNST in short, please
remember this.
Now, let’s look at some results from this
technique.
This is what our simulation would look like
normally, and then, all we have to do is show
this image to the simulator, and, what does
it do with it?
Wow.
My goodness.
Just look at those heavenly patterns!
So what does today’s new, followup work
offer to us that the previous one doesn’t?
How can this seemingly nearly perfect technique
be improved?
Well, this new work takes an even more brazen
vantage point to this question.
If style transfer on density fields is hard,
then try a different representation.
The title of the paper says Lagrangian style
neural style transfer.
So what does that mean?
It means particles!
This was made for particle-based simulations,
which comes with several advantages.
One, because the styles are now attached to
particles, we can choose different styles
for different smoke plumes, and they will
remember what style they are supposed to follow.
Because of this advantageous property, we
can even ask the particles to change their
styles over time, creating these heavenly
animations.
In these 2D examples, you also see how the
texture of the simulation evolves over time,
and that the elements of the style are really
propagated to the surface and the style indeed
follows how the fluid changes.
This is true, even if we mix these styles
together.
Two, it not only provides us these high-quality
results, but, it is fast.
And by this, I mean blazing fast.
You see, we talked about TNST, the transport-based
technique approximately 7 months ago, and
in this series, I always note that two more
papers down the line, and it will be much,
much faster.
So here is the Two Minute Papers Moment of
Truth, what do the timings say?
For the previous technique, it said more than
1d.
What could that 1D mean?
Oh, goodness!
This thing took an entire day to compute.
So, what about the new one?
What, really?
Just one hour?
That is insanity.
So, how detailed of a simulation are we talking
about?
Let’s have a look together.
M slash f means minutes per frame, and as
you see, if we have tens of thousands of particles,
we have 0.05, or in other words, three seconds
per frame, and we can go up to hundreds of
thousands, or even millions of particles,
and end up around thirty seconds per frame.
Loving it.
Artists are going to do miracles with this
technique, I am sure.
The next step is likely going to be a real-time
algorithm, which may appear as soon as one
or two more works down the line, and you can
bet your papers that I’ll be here to cover
it, so make sure to subscribe, and hit the
bell icon to not miss it when it appears.
The speed of progress in computer graphics
research is nothing short of amazing.
Also, make sure to have a look at the full
paper in the video description, not only because
it is a beautiful paper and a lot of fun to
read, but because you will also know what
this regularization step here does exactly
to the simulation.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!